GET RELEASED IN THE U.S.
BACK TO YOU.
>> Gillian: WILLIAM
LA JEUNESSE IN L.A., THANK YOU.
MIKE?
>> Mike: LET’S BRING IN
BRANDON JED, PRESIDENT OF THE
NATIONAL BORDER PATROL COUNSEL.
WELCOME.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING ME.
LET ME START BY SAYING EVERY
SINGLE U.S. CITIZEN SHOULD BE
FURIOUS ABOUT THE ACTIONS OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION, TRYING TO
OVERTURN A POLICY THAT HAS BEEN
PROVEN TO WORK.
THEN OF COURSE THEY USE RHETORIC
INSTEAD OF ACTUAL FACTS WHEN
THEY SAY THAT IT PUTS THEM UNDER
UNACCEPTABLE CONDITIONS.
THEY DON’T HAVE ANY FACTS
WHATSOEVER, OR EVIDENCE TO PROVE
THAT THOSE CONDITIONS ARE
UNACCEPTABLE.
THAT IS RHETORIC THEY ARE TRYING
TO DEFLECT FROM THEIR FAILURES
ON THE BORDER AND ALL OF THIS IS
GOING TO CAUSE EVEN MORE CHAOS
AND PUT MORE PRESSURE ON OUR
AGENTS TO GET THE JOB DONE
BETTER WHEN THEY CAN’T DO IT.
IT’S A POLICY THAT DICTATES WHAT
WE ARE ABLE TO DO.
>> Mike: WHY, IN YOUR VIEW,
BRANDON, IS REMAIN IN MEXICO SO
EFFECTIVE?
>> BECAUSE THE CARTELS
UNDERSTAND AND RECOGNIZE ALL OF
OUR MOVEMENTS.
THEY SURVEILLANCE, THEY WATCH
US.
THEY KNOW HOW MANY AGENTS WE
HAVE IN THE FIELD AT ANY GIVEN
TIME.
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT IF THEY
FLOOD A CERTAIN AREA WITH A
LARGE NUMBER OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, IT TAKES MORE OF OUR
AGENTS OUT OF THE FIELD.
WHEN THEY DO THAT, THEY ARE ABLE
TO CROSS HIGHER-VALUE PRODUCTS.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED YESTERDAY.
CBP SAID EIGHT-WEEK BY CHRIS
CLEMENT OUT OF YUMA, ARIZONA,
WAS LAW ENFORCEMENT SENSITIVE.
THAT WAS NOT LAW ENFORCEMENT
SENSITIVE.
THAT WAS INFORMATION THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC SHOULD HAVE, HAS
A RIGHT TO KNOW, AND YET CBP
FORCED HIM TO TAKE THAT TWEET
DOWN BECAUSE IT WAS EMBARRASSING
EMBARRASSING.
THAT IS WHY IT’S SO IMPORTANT.
THE CRIMINAL CARTELS DO NOT FEAR
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHAT THEY FEAR IS POLICY.
THEY FEAR IF THEY’RE GOING TO BE
PROSECUTED, THEY FEAR IF MPP
WILL BE BROUGHT BACK, BECAUSE
THEN THEY CAN’T GO INTO
COUNTRIES AND ADVERTISE THEIR
SERVICES AND MAKE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OFF OUR POLICIES.
>> Mike: I WANT TO PLAY A CLIP
FROM FORMER ACTING DHS SECRETARY
CHAD WOLF.
>> WE KNOW THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DOESN’T LIKE THE
POLICY.
THIS LATEST PLOY TO ASK THE
SUPREME COURT TO OVERRULE IT IS
YET ANOTHER ISSUE WITH A
MESSAGING.
YOU CAN’T EMBLEM OF THE PROGRAM
AT THE SAME TIME SAY YOU WANT TO
DISMANTLE THE PROGRAM AND THINK
THAT’S GOING TO RESONATE WITH
MIGRANTS AND CARTEL MEMBERS AND
OTHER SMUGGLERS.
>> Mike: WHY IS THE
ADMINISTRATION SO EAGER TO HAVE
THE SUPREME COURT STEP IN HERE?
>> THEY ARE PANDERING TO THEIR
OPEN BORDER BASE.
THEY UNDERSTAND THEY HAVE A HUGE
PROBLEM.
THEIR NUMBERS ARE UNDERWATER IN
EVERY SINGLE CATEGORY, WHETHER
IT’S THE ECONOMY, BORDER
SECURITY, FOREIGN AFFAIRS.
THEY ARE UNDERWATER IN
EVERYTHING SO THEY TRYING TO
ENERGIZE THEIR BASE.
THAT’S ALL THEY’RE DOING.
THE OTHER GOOD THING WE CAN FALL
BACK ON AS WE KNOW THE
SUPREME COURT IS GOING TO RULE
AGAINST THE ADMINISTRATION
BECAUSE THE MPP IS PERFECTLY
LAWFUL.
THEREFORE WE ARE IN A GOOD
POSITION, BUT ALL THIS DOES IS
IT ALLOWS THE ADMINISTRATION TO
SLOW-WALK THE REIMPLEMENTATION
OF MPP, WHICH IS WHAT THEY’RE
TRYING TO DO.
>> Mike: IT SOUNDS LIKE THE
PROBLEM IS EXTENDING BEYOND
TEXAS AND ARIZONA.
THERE ARE NOW QUESTIONS BEING
ASKED IN PENNSYLVANIA ABOUT
IMMIGRANTS BEING FLOWN IN THERE.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THE
SITUATION IN PENNSYLVANIA AND
OTHER STATES FAR BEYOND TEXAS
AND ARIZONA?
>> THIS IS HAPPENING EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
WHEN WE TAKE CHILDREN INTO
CUSTODY, OR UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS, WE TURN THEM OVER TO
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AND
THEY THEN FLY THEM THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES, INCLUDING
PENNSYLVANIA, AND DO IT UNDER
THE COVER OF NIGHT BECAUSE THEY
DON’T WANT THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT’S GOING ON.
THE REASON WHY THIS IS SO SCARY
IS ALL WE HAVE TO DO IS LOOK AT
FLORIDA.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
24-YEAR-OLD WHO CLAIMS HE WAS 17
YEARS OLD WHEN HE WAS BRANDED BY
THE BORDER PATROL AND HE WAS
FLOWN TO FLORIDA AND HE KILLED
SAN FRANCISCO
HEAVIER
NOT HIS STEPFATHER, BUT THE HOME
THAT THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES PLACED HIM IN.
THAT’S WHY IT IS SO SCARY AND
WHY THE PUBLIC SHOULD HAVE A
RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING.
BECAUSE IT’S EMBARRASSING, THEY
DON’T LET THE PUBLIC NOW AND
THEY TRY TO HIDE IT UNDER THE